[Musik]
meine damen und herren es ist viertel
nach acht herzlich willkommen bei
viertel nach acht fünf köpfe fünf
meinung das ist unser motto nicht
begrüße ganz herzlich im studio die frau
auf die die fdp seit jahren gewartet hat
claudia vision 2020 eingetreten in die
partei schon ein jahr später mitglied
des bundestages und jetzt sitzt sie in
zwei mächtigen und wichtigen ausschüssen
den ausschüssen haushalt und finanzen
dann begrüße ich ganz herzlich einer
klügsten journalistischen köpfe in
deutschland harald martenstein publizist
und kolumnist aktuell auch in diensten
der welt
ich begrüße ganz herzlich einen mann der
aus der heimlichen kanzler hauptstadt
contest cdu bundestagsabgeordneter er
ist verkehrsexperte und er ist chef der
heimlichen kanzler hauptstadt hamburg
aus der schon drei bundeskanzler kamen
und kommen herzlich willkommen christoph
ploß und ich begrüße ganz herzlich meine
sehr geschätzten kollegen hierbei bild
sebastian geisler
scharfsinniger analytiker der deutschen
politik und ein wirklich pointierter
räder sie werden es gleich merken viel
spaß ich freue mich dass sie dabei sind
es gibt spannende themen über die wir
heute sprechen wollen mein name ist jan
schäfer und der nächsten knappen stunde
da geht es unter anderem um den teuer
schock es geht um corona es geht um
anstehende sozialreform es geht um
islamismus und es geht um den hier unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz gestartet mit
ganz ganz vielen
vorschusslorbeeren chef einer ampel
partei spd grüne und fdp und hat eine
zeitenwende ausgerufen ende februar nach
dem kreml diktator wladimir putin die
ukraine überfallen hat doch muss sagen
18 wochen jetzt später stellte fest olaf
scholz hat aus dem kanzleramt eher ein
schneckenhaus gemacht er steht auf der
bremse und jetzt kommt sogar das
internationale us magazin time und
lästert über den bundeskanzler mächtig
ab die teamkollegin wirft olaf scholz
vor er zaudere zu lange auch der jüngste
beschluss endlich schwere waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern der sei nur zustande
gekommen aufgrund von internationalem
druck will see hat olaf scholz der immer
wieder bremst bremst brems seine worte
fressen muss und der am ende kein macher
ist doch das ist genau das was wir
brauchen im kanzleramt da darf kein
bremser sitzen da muss ein macher sitzen
in deutschland eine wichtige
führungsnation dieser welt und wer auf
dauer nein sagt der hat irgendwann gar
nichts mehr zu sagen das darf unserem
land nicht passieren
herr martenstein scholz ist es kommt ich
kenne immer nicht also ich meine ganz im
ernst ich weiß nicht wofür er steht ich
weiß nicht was er will
bei merkel wusste man das so ansatzweise
ich habe das gefühl wir leben in so
einer fortsetzung der ära merkel nur
nicht so unterhaltsam wenn ich stolz
reden höre
wenn ich immer sofort müde und
zum beispiel diese panzerlieferungen die
jetzt erfolgen sollen die gebhard panzer
für die scheint es ja nicht ausreichend
munition zu geben und es dauert auch
eine halbe ewigkeit bis man die leute
ausgebildet hat damit sie mit diesem
fenster was machen sollen ich weiß nicht
warum man da nicht gummibärchen
geliefert hat ehrlich also ich bin es
gab ja mal 5000 haley beliefert worden
aber das war auch ein witz also
gummibärchen werden wahrscheinlich dann
die größte last hätte vorstellen können
ich bin ein bisschen sarkastisch dass
wenn manche vielleicht unpassend finden
aber dieses hin und her
was die ukraine politik angeht und was
waffenlieferungen an geht das hat schon
was sehr unwürdiges finde ich diese
leute kämpfen um ihr leben kämpfen um
ihr land sie haben wirklich keine zeit
und wenn man ihnen nicht helfen will
dann soll man es begründen und dann soll
man es sagen dass man sich jetzt ihr
kanzler über den harten stein so spricht
das muss ihnen doch wahnsinnig weh tun
oder sie haben olaf scholz mit gewählt
also kann man das so stehen lassen was
hartensteiner sagt ja dass also das ist
so ankommt in der bevölkerung kann man
verstehen also er hat halt seine art die
dinge anzugehen kommt bei ihnen auch so
an
ich habe ihn jetzt so persönlich leider
noch nicht kennen lernen dürfen aber
ehrlich gesagt vermisse ich ihn auch ein
bisschen also ich bin halt ein typ ich
mag gerne führungspersönlichkeiten
jemand der da steht und klare
ja klar redet sondern ist olaf scholz
weil er sich im kanzleramt einen bunker
oder dahin zurück zu vermissen eine
starke führungspersönlichkeit wo ich
auch das gefühl hätte okay er hat das im
griff und ja der friedrich merz jetzt
ihnen lieber als kanzler in dieser
situation
den kenne ich auch nicht persönlich also
ich mache es jetzt wirklich an
persönlichen sachen
fest ja also das problem ist wir hatten
halt keine gute auswahl sag ich jetzt
einfach mal so nah und wir haben
irgendwie mit unseren kanzlern immer
schon eine komische sache gab dass
schröder er sozialdemokrat war fand ich
schon komisch hätte ich jetzt auch nicht
tippen können dass die märke
christdemokraten ist fand ich auch
passten nicht so und jetzt haben wir in
schutz ich
würde friedrich merz auf jeden fall für
den besseren kanzler halbes jahrhundert
los nein also das ist aber natürlich ein
wichtiger punkt wir haben in deutschland
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten in vielen
fragen auch führung an den tag gelegt
das war unter sozialdemokratischen
kanzler so das war auch unter
christdemokratischen kanzlern so immer
auch in enger zusammenarbeit mit anderen
europäischen nachbarstaaten auch mit
kleineren staaten das war zum beispiel
kann sein wie helmut kohl ganz wichtig
und dadurch hatte deutschland immer eine
ganz besondere rolle in europa im
positiven sinne jetzt haben wir diese
besondere rolle im negativen sinne weil
wir hinterher dackeln mit der ampel
koalition mit olaf scholz als
bundeskanzler weil entscheidungen
teilweise innerhalb von wenigen tagen
komplett wieder
verworfen werden man weiß nicht woran
ist man es gibt keine klare
kommunikationslinie und die anderen
staaten gerade kleinere länder wie
estland wie liter und die gehen im
moment voran und irgendwann ist der
druck so groß auf und stolz dass er
nachgeben muss wir haben den druck ja
auch in dieser woche auf olaf scholz und
die ampel koalition entfacht beim thema
waffenlieferung aber wir brauchen
natürlich auf dauer eine bundesregierung
die aufführt und die regiert und die
nicht nur aufgrund des öffentlichen
drucks reagiert sebastian geisler war
das erwartet dass olaf scholz
sich so einmal zurückzieht auch in
seinem kanzleramt wie wir es gerade
sehen hätte es wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich erwarten können wenn man
sich einfach anschauen wie ist er denn
eigentlich kanzler geworden er hat sich
ja relativ passiv gegeben nach dem motto
hohen nicht großen negativ auffallen im
wahlkampf und dann wird schon der spd
balken am tag der bundestagswahl war
irgendwie irgendwas über 20% land und
dann die union knapp übertrumpfen genau
das ist ja auch passiert nur er ist
jetzt eben ermahnt und er muss jetzt
tatsächlich führen und es musste ja
sogar offensichtlich so weit kommen dass
im ausland der eindruck entstanden ist
deutschland steht auf der falschen seite
der geschichte also so dramatisch im
grunde bis scheut sich bewegt hat und
jetzt endlich handelt und das ist
natürlich eine ein reputationsschaden
der deutschen außenpolitik das wird
möglicherweise jahrzehnte dauern das
wieder in ordnung zu meist auch nicht es
ist ja auch nicht das erste mal ne
stichwort nord stream da haben wir das
vor einigen monaten und einigen wochen
erlebt da haben gerade die
sozialdemokraten in deutschland noch an
nordstream zwei festgehalten als
eigentlich alles schon gesagt haben also
die inbetriebnahme die kann nicht
erfolgen und jetzt haben wir das gleiche
bei den waffenlieferungen erlebt und
eben auch bei vielen anderen fragen und
wenn das so weitergeht dann ist
deutschland international wirklich
blamiert und dann wird es ganz ganz
lange dauern bis dieser reputation
schaden wieder behoben ist ist es denn
so also
sieht das ausland das so ihn als
schwachen kanzler oder schätzt man
vielleicht seine souveränität dass er
sich nicht raus senkt und jetzt also ja
aber das thema gesehen hat auch die wahl
zur miss world gekürt also das time
magazine hat durchaus nach der bild
zeitung würde ich sagen
macht und power und kann auch gewisse
trends aufnehmen und möglicherweise auch
verstärkender martenstein sie haben mal
einer kolumne ein paar wochen her olaf
scholz angela merkel und helmut schmidt
miteinander verglichen zumindest auch
deren herkunft dass er beim thema
heimliche kanzleramt hamburg und haben
gesagt offenbar lieben die deutschen
dass ein kanzler pragmatisch und spröde
ist ja
es ist ja auffällig dass von den kanzler
der letzten jahrzehnte
schmidt der einzige ist dennoch ein
positives image hat bei den leuten und
eine lichtgestalt ist kohl hatte die
spendenaffäre das schwarze die schwarzen
konten am bein und brüssel den
ehrenvorsitz abgeben schröder naja da
weiß man ja und bei angela merkel ist
natürlich die reputation jetzt auch
beschädigt durch die falsche russland
politik durch die
zusammenbrechende infrastruktur dieses
landes durch die probleme der
bildungspolitik und so weiter und so
weiter das erbe ist ja zumindest sagen
wenn man fragwürdig die cdu kann das ja
nicht offen sagen weil bei jedem finger
den sie in richtung merkel strikt weisen
ja 54 auf santa punkt das heißt sie
sagen die deutschen wählen sich immer
mal wieder oder am in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten sich den falschen kanzler
eigentlich gewählt na ja wir haben nur
mein demokratisches system insofern kann
man sich den falschen kratz leid nicht
wählen weil ich meine der der es wird
der der ist es eben aber die sehnsucht
der leute ist glaube ich schon dass da
einer steht und
sagt was er denkt und was er will daran
kann man sich ja dann auch reiben
gegebenenfalls und das ist ja die große
stärke von scholz hauptrivalen das ist
natürlich der grüne haben der natürlich
mit großen rhetorischen gaben gesegnet
ist und dem man abnimmt dass er egal wie
man es findet auch wenn man es falsch
findet dass er das sagt was er denkt
gerne schon und auch seine gefühle zeigt
das ist natürlich eine art und weise von
politik die nicht nur bei mir sondern
bei vielen anderen leuten auch gut
ankommt ich bin wirklich kein fan dieser
partei aber ich bin ich habe großen
respekt davor wie habe ich das macht und
vor der folie habig sieht scholz
natürlich nicht gut aus also mehr gefühl
in der politik ist glaube ehrlich das
was sich ehrlichkeit auch da würde man
stolz unterstellen er ist nicht ehrlich
wird sich das unterstellen nein das
unterstelle ich ihn nicht aber
vielleicht ist er ist nicht offen das
bessere wort ja denn was er wirklich an
motiven hat für diesen eiertanz mit den
waffenlieferungen
das sagt er uns ja nicht er rückt ja
nicht damit raus warum er das erst nicht
wollte und er rückt auch nicht wirklich
damit heraus warum er dann doch mit
diesen 100 tans ändern angedacht km h
und er lässt vor allem seinen worten
endlich taten vor wir haben ja alle
erlebte der deutschen bundestag ende
februar diese historische debatte und
seine worte jetzt muss die zeitenwende
kommen und genau diese zeitenwende ist
bis heute nicht erfolgt wer die
bundeswehr hat immer noch mit großen
problemen zu kämpfen er hat seine eigene
partei nicht so richtig unter kontrolle
da gibt es jetzt schon diskussion es
soll kein militarismus geben der
fraktionsvorsitzende ich hatte in dieser
woche noch davor gewarnt dass die
ukraine mit schweren waffen beliefert
werden soll dann hat er druck irgendwann
gewirkt jetzt haben wir das zum glück
heute hier im deutschen bundestag
beschlossen aber man merkt diese
zeitenwende die es einmal ausgesprochen
worden ist ein schönes wort aber das ist
noch nicht in politisches handeln
umgemünzt worden und wir brauchen jetzt
führung gerade in diesen zeiten ich habe
vieles von dem was gerade eben hier am
tisch gesagt wurde das treibt auch die
bild leserinnen und leser um die
zuschauer denn wir haben gefragt gestern
einmal wie müsste eigentlich der super
kanzler aussehen was für eigenschaften
müsste er mitbringt und herausgekommen
ist genau das hier wir sehen dass die
unter haben zehntausende ihre stimme
abgegeben dass 16 prozent der meinung
sind die wirtschaftskompetenz von
friedrich merz die muss ein kanzler
unbedingt haben das kann man glaube ich
ganz gut sehen hier an der neuen brille
von friedrich merz aber auch ganz
interessant die entschlossenheit ihrer
parteifreundin der fdp
verteidigungsexpertin genau marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann das ist die dame mit
dem grauen haar ganz entscheidend finden
16 prozent derjenigen die mitgemacht
haben für ganz ganz wichtig für einen
bundeskanzler dann sehen wir helu quenz
christian den elf prozent sagen das ist
ganz ganz wichtig aber auch die
bodenständigkeit malu dreyer die
spd-regierungschefs von
rheinland-pfalz auch das wird als
wichtig angesehen und
schlagfertigkeit da sind wir bei dem
thema ein bisschen mehr gefühl zeigen
ein bisschen mehr
offenheit die schlagfertigkeit von
barbara schöneberger
die wünschen sich auch so und jetzt muss
ich einmal selbst schauen wo es wenn ihr
bei der schöneberger irgendwo ist hier
auch barbara schöneberger darin das ist
empathie sieht auch so aus also so in
meine damen und herren und hier auch in
der runde sieht sehen viele viele
deutsche den optimalen super kanzler
wir haben doch heute abend ein bisschen
was dazugelernt für jede partei ganz
wichtig erwarten straßen ein bisschen
wirkt das ein bisschen wenig friedrich
merz aber drin dann können wir uns
unserem perfekten kanzler ja nicht
backen also noch eine chance geben also
wenn wir jetzt schon beim vergleich von
kanzlern sind so hat mir eine
vorgängerin die ad hoc in
krisensituationen in meinen augen falsch
reagiert also das war die
migrationspolitik und fukushima so
einfach aus dem bauch raus und deswegen
bin ich schon froh dass er irgendwie
sich sammelt und ich hoffe nur dass er
überwiegend in diesen tagen brauchen wir
jemanden der führung zeigt und nicht der
sich noch lange sammeln muss also das
ist eben jahren das über den kanzler
gesprochen aber der kanzler regiert
nicht allein es gibt einen kabinett und
damit möchte ich an sie übergeben herr
martenstein das thema kabinett ist
wichtig es geht um karl lauterbach aber
vor möchte ich sagen dass ich unbedingt
für barbara schöneberger als kanzlerin
und ich bin ziemlich sicher dass es bei
einer abstimmung zwischen den hier
genannten kandidaten eine klare siegerin
geben wird
wir
freuen uns jetzt auf den sommer und wir
alle haben machen uns sorgen
wegen des ukraine krieges aber es gibt
ja auch noch corona das ist ja nicht weg
der herbst wird kommen das steht fest
und es ist sicher nützlich zu wissen wie
wir uns eigentlich geschlagen haben in
der pandemie wie die sogenannte
maßnahmen gewirkt haben was war richtig
was wir falsch was war übertrieben und
um das herauszufinden
tut die regierung das was nach jedem
seminar gemacht wird eine evaluation
wird gestartet heißt unabhängige
experten schauen sie sich das an
unabhängiger und bilden sich ein urteil
darüber und sehr sinnvoll und das will
karl lauterbach der gesundheitsminister
offenbar nicht
er hat einen brief geschrieben an die
bundestagspräsidentin er sagt
dass es um über die maßnahmen also er
lehnt das nicht in bausch und bogen habt
nur den teil in dem es um die maßnahmen
geht damit meine ich lockdown
schulschließungen und dergleichen
um die maßnahmen wirklich beurteilen zu
können viele die datenbasis und deswegen
sollte man doch bitte diese das
veröffentlichung dieser evaluation
mindestens auf den sommer 2023 schieben
ein jahr warum die daten die jetzt
angeblich nicht da sind 2023 plötzlich
da sein sollen weiß ich auch nicht aber
für herrn lauterbach wäre eine solche
verschiebung natürlich unglaublich
praktisch denn der herbst kann kommen er
kann wieder für schulschließungen und
harte maßnahmen trommeln das macht er
gerne das ist so sein stil gewesen
letzter in den letzten jahren ohne dass
irgend ein unabhängiges gremium mal
genau drauf geguckt hätte was das
wirklich bringt was er da alles will und
das kommt dazu er kann sich schon
vorstellen was in dieser evaluation
stehen wird unser nachbarland die
schweiz hat nämlich schon eine gemacht
deutschland ist ja recht oft ein
bisschen langsam auch in diesem fall war
es dass die schweizer waren schnelle
haben evaluiert und was kam dabei heraus
vor allem die schulschließungen seien
nicht verhältnismäßig gewesen weil der
nutzen den sie für die pandemie
bekämpfung gehabt haben in gar keinem
verhältnis stand zu dem schaden den die
bildungsbiografien von kindern und
jugendlichen haben das befürchtet
lauterbach glaube ich wird auch in der
deutschen evaluation stehen und das
sollen die leute natürlich möglichst
erst 2023 erfahren nachdem herr
lauterbach den schulen vielleicht wieder
mal dicht gemacht hat aber es gibt noch
eine sache muss ich noch sagen weil das
ist an dieser ganzen geschichte
für mich das gruseligste und
sonderbarsten wer sitzt in dieser
unabhängigen kommission die von außen
auf das werk der regierung blicken soll
es sollte darin sitzen der virologe der
maßgeblich diese maßnahmen beeinflusst
hat der wichtigste ratgeber dieser
politik nämlich herr droste der sitzt
also da und soll sich sein eigenes
schulzeugnis schreiben das war die idee
die idee ist nicht aufgegangen weil
wolfgang kubicki einen
brandbrief geschrieben hat gegen diese
sache ist jurist und er sagt dass also
es gibt ja auch so was wie
unabhängigkeit und unbefangenheit und
das ist ja hier in diesem fall überhaupt
nicht gegeben also ist hat es gibt ist
das geplatzt aber herr lauterbach finde
das sehr schade dabei brauchen wir so
eine evaluation ja gar nicht wenn wir ja
wir brauchen nur in unsere nachbarländer
zu gucken sie haben die schweiz genannt
wir haben ja noch dänemark die haben
dann die kinder keine masken tragen in
der schule schweden und dann gucken uns
die zahlen an und das ist auch nicht ein
mensch mehr gestorben als bei uns also
diese gründung fand ich schon immer ein
bisschen fadenscheinig muss natürlich
schauen was das für virus ist mit dem
was im herbst zu tun haben das weiß aber
niemand niemand weiß dass ein
killervirus wie der gesundheitsminister
ist er noch der geeignete
gesundheitsminister frau raffelhüschen
für dieses land das ja nicht nur corona
als problem im gesundheitsministerium
kennt sonne ja viele viele andere
probleme auch noch
gemeinde
weil zu laut aber habe ich ein ganz
spezielles verhältnis auf was ihre
gesundheitspolitik vorher schon
anbelangt hat und ich sehe in ihm jemand
der dieses thema legt der sich damit
profiliert und jetzt sehen wir dass
bröckelt ja also wir tragen keine masken
mehr und ich spüre irgendwie dass das
ihm so sein kind abhandenkommt und das
ärgert mich ein bisschen also die
rationalität
fehlt mir her und
hat auch ihn als experten
auszuweisen nur weil er in harvard
gesundheitsökonomie studiert hat das hat
mich auch immer gestört dieses harvard
und ja also ich persönlich hätte mir
jemand anderen gewünscht
er war ja während der kroner phase
wirklich gerade am ende so eine art
alarm oder angst minister und man hat
teilweise den eindruck gehabt als dann
das thema corona nicht mehr so in der
öffentlichkeit war dann hat er auch so
ein bisschen darunter gelitten weil er
selber nicht mehr so in der
öffentlichkeit war und das ist natürlich
für einen minister immer schlechten
minister muss sagen ich kümmere mich um
die probleme die das land hat und
versuche in meinem bereich das
bestmögliche zu tun aber das darf kein
selbstzweck sein dass so ein thema ein
dann nach vorne spielt das ist das eine
das andere ist das ja auch bedeutende
virologen in deutschland wie zum
beispiel hendrik streek immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen haben dass wir
natürlich einerseits
virologisch das ganze betrachten müssen
aber immer auch andere perspektiven
einnehmen müssen zum beispiel welche
kollateralschäden gibt es für
jugendliche für kinder für
gewerbetreibende nicht für unternehmer
was bedeutet das für arbeitsplätze und
ein guter politiker der kann natürlich
dass nicht nur eindimensional betrachten
sondern der muss immer mehrere
perspektiven einnehmen und die dann
abwägen und mir hat während der korona
phase häufig dieser mehrdimensionale
blick gefehlt das war dann immer sehr
einseitig virologisch hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass man vielleicht manchmal
häufiger auftaucht ob virologen wie
henrik strikt gehört hätte sie haben das
thema popularität angesprochen wir haben
ja gesehen dass in den umfragen auch die
wir wöchentlich mit dem institut ennser
durchführen über wochen karl lauterbach
der beliebteste minister war auch noch
vor olaf scholz mittlerweile liegen
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
vorne dann kommt der bundeskanzler und
er im rahmen platzsituation platz sechs
bewegt sich mittlerweile karl lauterbach
also treibt ihn das um das er da
abgestürzt ist hat harald martenstein
recht wenn er sagt es geht ihm darum
einfach auch wieder in die
öffentlichkeit zu kommen dinge jetzt
nicht nach nicht aufklären zu wollen um
dann im herbst ein hartes regime wieder
führen zu können genau also ich glaube
er vom lehrer genießt zum einen die
popularität die er zwischenzeitlich hat
die hat er durch corona das ist ganz
klar ohne krone wäre er nicht
gesundheitsminister geworden tatsächlich
und wenn man sich mal offen aussprechen
er hat offensichtlich angst dass bei
dieser evaluierung dieser hinten
rauskommt dass diese maßnahmen nicht
sinnvoll waren geschadet haben finde ich
verhältnismäßig waren was auch
verfassungsrechtlicher sehr relevant ist
weil die massnahmen verhältnismässig und
sinnvoll sein müssen was eigentlich
sogar konkret bewiesen werden muss und
das wäre ja eben eigentliche sinn einer
solchen untersuchung und genau ich
glaube auch er steht auf den nächsten
herbst hat schon wieder irgendwie sich
überlegt was da an verschärfungen wieder
kommen könnte unserem alter und die kann
er nicht so ohne weiteres durchsetzen
wenn jetzt eine solche untersuchung im
dazwischen hagelt und das ist das
problem wieso gibt es eigentlich von der
union kein ausschuss keine forderung
nach einem untersuchungsausschuss
in sachen corona krone auf arbeit und
christian lindner hat auch wahlkampf
gemacht mit der forderung dass houston
welt es müsse nach dem nach den
bundestagswahlen nach der ende der
korona pandemie ein
untersuchungsausschuss ein
parlamentarischer viele dinge halten
werden vielleicht so christian lehnert
und der fdp da gibt ja in christian
lindner 1 und christian lindner 2 den
christian linder 1 das war der vor der
wahl der auch viele gute sachen
gefordert hatte und für die ihr
wahlkampf gemacht hat beispielsweise
einhaltung der schuldenbremse nicht
immer mehr schulden machen reform in der
rentenpolitik und auch bei corona maß
und mitte zu wahren da ganz viele
sinnvolle vorschläge davon wird nur
leider jetzt gar nichts umgesetzt bei
christian lindner 2 gibt es eine
komplett gegenteilige politik ich
persönlich bin aber der meinung dass wir
in dieser ausserordentlichen krisenzeit
jetzt auch wirklich überparteilich alle
kräfte darauf bündeln sollten die
aussenpolitischen krisen bestmöglich zu
überwinden und einen
untersuchungsausschuss der kostet viel
zeit der kostet viel kraft gekostet
viele ressourcen deswegen wäre ich eher
der meinung dass man sagen muss was
können wir aus den vorhergegangenen
wellen lernen was bedeutet eine jetzige
evaluation und wie können wir
bestmöglich gerüstet dann in den herbst
gehen dann lassen sie uns einmal daran
cut machen herbst das würde ja fast
bedeutet ich das mal überspitzt dass wir
die hälfte des bundestags gar nicht mehr
brauchen dann die hälfte der minister
nicht mehr war ja nichts mehr zu tun ist
außer
nicht ob er eine idee über suchen
kümmern sebastian aber das wort
christian lindner ist gefallen das
stichwort christian lindner das thema
schulden oder sind wir bei dem thema
auch von dir es geht um den topf haben
sie sich nicht auch schon mal gefragt
liebe zuschauer mensch warum wohnen ich
dann eigentlich längst im eigenheim mit
garten oder in eine eigentumswohnung
vielleicht meine eltern meine großeltern
die kollegen die ein paar jahre älter
sind da aber die preise so massiv
gestiegen sind es ist entsetzlich wenn
sie mal schauen bei den einschlägigen
immobilienportalen früher aber jetzt
doch noch eine zwei zimmer wohnung in
berlin britz oder 60.000 70.000 euro
rund 380.000 euro je nachdem natürlich
wo sie regional gucken aber das ist ein
masten für ein drastischer preisanstieg
und deswegen kommen viele menschen auch
aus der mittelschicht in deutschland
nicht mehr ins wohneigentum das ist für
viele vollkommen unerschwinglich
geworden aber woran liegt denn das
manche behaupten jetzt ja ja die jungen
leute die neben gerne mal so ein coffee
to go auf die hand mit ist ja kein
wunder wenn man so lebt da kann man sich
natürlich ein haus leisten dass
vernebelt die wahren ursachen die wahre
ursache ist nämlich die politik der
europäischen zentralbank an der spitze
christine lagarde an der iss an der ezb
spitze die nämlich den nullzins
geschaffen bzw aufrecht erhält der
nullzins wir müssen noch mal klar sagen
viele haushalte viele staaten in europa
vor allem in südeuropa sind schwer
verschuldet zum beispiel italien und die
kämen wirklich an den rande eines starts
ruins wenn jetzt der leitzins stieg
deswegen macht die ezb das nicht hält
den leitzins schön auf null dadurch
verwerten dadurch steigen aber die
hauspreise ganz massiv die sogenannten
vermögenswerte werden immer teurer auch
aktien und das verschärft jetzt eben
ganz massiv die situation auch in
deutschland eben die soziale spaltung
die dadurch deutlich verschärfe das darf
nicht sein es kann nicht sein dass
südeuropäer zum beispiel auf kosten der
deutschen mittelschicht leben dass die
ezb die deutschen im grunde in die armut
zwingt das muss aufhören und ich möchte
auch dazu aufrufen sprechen sie mal
darüber sprechen tauschen sich aus mit
kollegen darüber sagen sie das mal das
muss endlich spread the word die leute
müssen das endlich verstehen diesen
mechanismus nullzins bedeutet wir kommen
nicht mehr ans eigenheim das ist der
preis dafür und er ist viel zu hoch das
muss aufhören und deshalb auch ganz
klarer appell an frau lagarde es muss
jetzt endlich mal der leitzins angehoben
werden handeln sie endlich wir erleben
dass sebastian zwar ein flammendes
plädoyer für eine leitzinserhöhung und
ich kann das nur voll und ganz
unterstreichen denn wir sehen ja das hat
ja ganz ganz viele verschiedene
schichten die dass dir der starrsinn der
ezb-spitze
dass das jetzt auch schon auswirkungen
hat auf den euro dollar kurs
beispielsweise und wenn der euro immer
schwächer werden das sehen wir gerade
dann bedeutet das beispielsweise das öl
das importiert werden muss noch teurer
wird also die um das verfahren der
nullzins heizt die inflation zusätzlich
an und am ende glaube ich ist das was du
gesagt absolut richtig das was wir jetzt
sehen ist die quittung für die
zinspolitik die nicht nur frau lagarde
gemacht hat sondern auch mario draghis
ist die quittung für die
griechen-rettung das ist in doppelter
hinsicht eine unsoziale politik wir sind
zum einen damals für die griechen die ja
massiv sparen mussten extrem hohe
arbeitslosigkeit riesige
jugendarbeitslosigkeit viel viel armut
und die zweite soziale folge daraus das
ist das zweite ungerecht ist dass wir
das in deutschland jetzt ganz ganz viele
millionen auch spüren nämlich
beispielsweise durch hauseigentum dass
man sich selbst nicht mehr lassen kann
es ist wenn ich das sagen darf ja so
eine art große enteignungs aktion die da
stattfindet und in vielerlei hinsicht
eine zeitbombe die leute kriegen ja erst
ganz allmählich mit was da eigentlich
passiert mit dem geld das sie gespart
haben und irgendwann haben sie es dann
aber auch alle gemerkt und dann werden
wir sicher soziale unruhen bekommen von
denen wir uns heute noch keine
vorstellungen machen als folge dieser
politik ein aspekt fehlt ja noch bei dem
was sie gesagt haben was ich schon
richtig finde das eigene haus und die
eigene wohnung sind ja so die
beliebteste altersvorsorge der
mittelschicht gewesen ja und wenn das
verschwindet und es verschwindet ja im
moment dann werden leute die ihr leben
lang ganz ordentlich verdient haben in
die armut weil sie die mieten die
selbstverständlich steigen im
rentenalter nicht mehr bezahlen können
früher hat man eben relativ günstig im
eigenen haus eine wohnung gewohnt das
ist eine große gruppe die da enteignet
wird dass es eine große gruppe die da im
alter in einer art sozialer vernichtung
geschickt wird es ist vielleicht ein
hartes wort aber wenn die leute dann
wirklich am inter eines arbeitsreichen
lebens vor dem nichts stehen dann werden
sie das da muss man kein prophet sein
dann werden sie ziemlich sauer sein mal
wer in europa eine der geringsten
eigentümer quoten haben ich glaube in
ganz europa ist nur die schweiz noch
schlechter aufgestellt also in vielen
ländern haben 80 90 prozent der
bevölkerung ein eigenes haus oder eine
eigene wohnung und dementsprechend dann
in solchen zeiten auch nicht ganz so
große probleme dann aber diejenigen die
zur miete wohnen die auch keine
eigentums immobilie haben die sind
natürlich dann auch noch besonders
getroffen und deswegen bedeutet das aus
meiner sicht das ist zwar eine
langfristige antwort aber dies auch sehr
wichtig dass die wehr ein nicht ein volk
der mieter auf dauer sein sollten
sondern wir müssen ein volk der
eigentümer werden das ist für mich auch
eine soziale frage
aber wo sie es sagen mit den eigentümern
die die die eigentum haben die leiden
natürlich auch nicht unter der inflation
die sich jetzt ergeben hat aber man muss
der ehrlichkeit auch venen dass es
früher teurer war also in absoluten
zahlen gebe ich ihnen recht 60.000 euro
für eine zweizimmerwohnung aber man
musste früher wesentlich länger für
eigentum arbeiten als man es heute muss
also auch die niedrigen zinsen machen es
uns auch leichter kredit aufzunehmen um
eine wohnung zu erwerben steigen die
bauzinsen ihre arbeit in löhne sind auch
enorm gestiegen sie schlafen unvergessen
als ist doch immer so aber
ich frage mich ob wir da nicht in eine
in eine ausweglose situation hinein
gesteuert sind denn was wird denn
passieren wenn die zinsen tatsächlich
wieder steigen was wird dann mit diesem
schuldenstaaten passieren ist werden die
da nicht in eine
zusammenbrechen und eine unglaubliche
krise geraten wir sind also in eines
innovation hineingekommen in der welt
sozusagen zwischen zwei großen krisen
die wahl haben die im süden oder die bei
uns und ich weiß irgendjemand hier eine
lösung wie zb das ist doch gaben das
haben sie vollkommen richtig analysiert
ist ja wenn man so will eine mutlose
zentralbanken man sich an die bundesbank
erinnert sich deutsche bundesbank in den
80ern aber auch in den 90er jahren dann
hatten wir ja zum teil zinsen die um ein
vielfaches 6 7 8 9 prozent leitzinsen
zum teil in 80er jahr im zweistelligen
bereich um ein vielfaches über dem lager
gut es gibt null zins dank an paris von
aber als was wir jetzt haben das heißt
da hat die politik die notenbank auch
ganz klar gegen den willen der
bundesregierung politik gemacht hat
gesagt es geht mir rein um
preisstabilität und um nichts anderes
und was hat die ezb jetzt gemacht viele
andere die hat einen trick sie hat erst
mal richtig ganz andere themen genommen
sie ist plötzlich fühlt sie sich als
grüner investor es hat überhaupt nichts
mit dem auftrag einer zentralbank zu tun
für preisstabilität zu sorgen dann hat
sie auch noch folgendes gemacht im
vergangenen sommer sie hat einfach ihr
preisstabilitätsziel das inflationsziel
geändert aus dem inflationsziel knapp
unter zwei prozent hat sie ein
mittelfristiges inflationsziel gemacht
was sie jetzt leicht die acht prozent
die wir ja fast schon haben
informationen mitnehmen lässt und dieses
jahres deutlich noch mal über zwei
prozent aber sie sagt ja aber im jahr
da rutschte wieder unter die 2 und
deswegen müssen wir nicht so gut wie
derzeit gar nichts machen also wir sehen
eine zentralbank die eigentlich zum
gehilfen zu massiven gehilfen eine
ausgabenpolitik wollen seiner
schuldenpolitik aber ihr eigenes nur
eines ziel aufgegeben hat und das ist
echt mit dem verein vor allem diejenigen
die nicht viel geld haben die können ja
häufig gar nicht sich die frage stelle
nach investiere ich jetzt mal ein oder
zwei immobilien und dann wachsen
vielleicht die der wächst der wert der
immobilien mit der inflation mit das ja
der gedanke den der häufig geäußert wird
sondern die sitzen da die haben das geld
auf dem konto designer für eine
immobilie reicht es nicht aktien sind
auch riskant gerade dann für ältere
leute weil man ehren aktien ja auch
investiert um langfristig vermögen
aufzubauen und die rentner die haben
dann keine andere möglichkeit als das
geld auf zu lassen und durch eine
inflation von sieben oder acht prozent
gibt es dann einen massiven
kaufkraftverlust und das merken ja
gerade die rentner auch wenn sie im
supermarkt gehen und lebensmittel kann
aber hat sich dann nicht die frage
schuldig ist der ezb mutlos oder ist sie
einfach zu abhängig
ich habe bloß abhängig also das ist
mario draghi der vorgänger von frau
lagarde hat ja immer die regierung in
europa aufgefordert hat ja gleichzeitig
nullzins am ende auf null gesenkt 20/16
hat gesagt wer jetzt müsst ihr reform
machen jetzt mit der reform machen aber
er hat nie ein ausstiegs zielgenau der
nie gesagt das machen wir jetzt bis 2019
drei jahre lang und für allem und in der
zeit müsst ihr was tun wenn nicht dann
habt ihr weltcups garbsen und heißt man
hat sich daran gewöhnt also sowie der
drogensüchtige sich an die drogen
gewöhnt hat hat man sich dann irgendwann
die niedrigzinsen gewöhnt sogar an -
zinsen ich weiß auch noch im
bundestagswahlkampf robert habeck der
hat gesagt wunderbar die zinssituation
jesu super nehmen wir über 500
milliarden euro auf um zum beispiel in
klimaschutz zu investieren so dass das
nicht von irgendjemanden im wahrsten
sinne des wortes bezahlt werden muss da
spielte in den diskussionen da keine
rolle mehr sondern alle angesagt als ob
dein geld wie manna vom himmel fällt man
kann das einfach aufnehmen und punkt und
dass das ein irrglaube ist und dass das
gerade diejenigen im land bezahlen
müssen die sowieso nicht viel geld haben
das ist das was jetzt immer mehr ins
bewusstsein der menschen kommt und ich
befürchte auch dass wir mit diesem
problem nicht nur in den nächsten
monaten leben müssen sondern
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten jahren
und deswegen auch meine forderung die
zinsen die müssten jetzt stark angehoben
werden dass wir gerade im sinne der
menschen die nicht so viel geld haben
aber es gibt kein hebel noch neue die
agravis zwingen noch mal die frage wie
realistisch ist das
denkmal gesetzt den fall dass die
südländer so verschuldet sind dass sie
mit höheren zinsen einfach nicht klar
kommen dass das problem wird nicht
zusammenbrechen lassen gigantische
hilfszahlungen oder eine monster
inflation in
europa ja die eurozone ist in einem auch
international wettbewerb das heißt wenn
in anderen regionen der welt auch die
zinsen jetzt an gehoben werden wie zum
beispiel in den usa dann kann die ezb
auch nicht sagen das interessiert uns
nicht weil sonst gelungen auch nur noch
sehr wenige investoren in europa es ist
auch nicht ihre aufgabe
die verschuldung irgendwie der angriff
zu einer sonder preisstabilität das ist
ihre aufgabe
einzig und allein martenstein sprach
gerade von der angst vor sozialen
unruhen kurzes kurze antwort von infra
zwischen teilen sie das dass wir
möglicherweise einigen jahren aufgrund
der politik der ezb soziale unruhen
haben das ist durchaus möglich ja also
wir kommen ja aus einer sehr
wohlhabenden zeit und jetzt bröckelt das
also viele leute ohne die menschen
machen sich sorgen über die
schuldenaufnahme und und je das
demografische problem da kommen wir
später noch darauf zu sprechen das lässt
sich auch nicht negieren oder abwenden
da kommen noch ordentlich probleme auf
und so also ordentlich probleme auf uns
zu das sagt claudia raffelhüschen
hierbei viertel nach acht mandaten wir
machen eine ganz kurze pause und sind
gleich wieder zurück es geht dann um
islamismus und anstehende soziale form
bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
sogar meine damen und herren bei 485
köpfen sind meinungen von jeder von uns
hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt
freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht privat jet buschi hergiswil
wetten seit august aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen hier einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
den leuten spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
vielleicht einmal kurz
doch das sind übliche anorak träger
ausdrücken und ich hatte meinen fall um
eine sache immer bekommt wer kümmert
sich darum niemand gibt sie ihr denn man
ist ja ganz knapp drüber sprechen das
ist ein fakt nicht der hat mich richtig
wohl ist die aufgabe von journalismus
einfach die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück meine damen
und herren bei viertel nach acht fünf
köpfe fünf meinung mit mir heute im
studio die fdp politikerin claudia
raffelhüschen der kolumnist harald
martenstein der cdu politiker christoph
ploß und mein geschätzter bild kollege
sebastian geisler ich bin jan schäfer
und wir machen direkt weiter und jetzt
geht es um das thema sozialreformen
claudia raffelhüschen also den
demografischen wandel können wir nicht
aufhalten aber wir müssen uns ihr
stellen also uns fehlen kinder an allen
ecken und enden zu wenig kinder um die
rente zu finanzieren wir haben zu wenig
kinder um die gesundheit zu finanzieren
und dann haben wir noch die
pflegeversicherung in meinen augen das
schwerst zu finanzierende problem was
auf uns zukommt und das gemeinste wenn
ich so ausdrücken darf ist dass wir
wissen dass dieses problem also wir
wissen ist ein über 30 jahren das ist
auf uns zukommt wir sind sehenden augen
sin ja in dieser situation gelaufen wir
haben wahlgeschenke gemacht wir haben
rentenerhöhungen durchgesetzt und jetzt
stehen wir vor einem großen
scherbenhaufen davon will ich noch nicht
sprechen aber wir stehen unter druck wir
müssen was tun wir müssen an unseren
sozialversicherungssystemen
arbeiten wir müssen reformen bringen
damit das in zukunft noch gut wird
also erstmal möchte ich sagen dass
diejenigen die jahrelang oder
jahrzehntelang hart gearbeitet haben die
müssen auch im alltag gut leben können
und deswegen auch eine auskömmliche
rente bekommen aber ich sehe auch mit
großer sorge dass der
generationenvertrag immer mehr bröckelt
und eigentlich neu aufgesetzt werden
muss das liegt an unterschiedlichen
faktoren die menschen werden
glücklicherweise immer älter bleiben
immer länger gesund und gleichzeitig das
haben sie eben völlig zu recht gesagt da
sind wir parteiübergreifend einer
meinung gibt es leider zu wenig kinder
und zu wenige arbeitnehmer die die
vielen rentner in deutschland oder die
vielen renten in deutschland dann
bezahlen können und deswegen brauchen
wir
generationenübergreifende reform wobei
mir immer auch ein und ganz wichtig ist
das würde ich auch ganz zu beginn einmal
sagen weil ja einige immer eine debatte
anführen denkmal an den dachdecker an
den möbelpacker und an diejenigen die
wirklich hart schuften finde ich völlig
richtig die auch in der debatte nach
vorne zu stellen und dass die natürlich
nicht mit 70 oder 75 hat körperliche
arbeit machen aber die sehr viele die
zum beispiel auch ein bürojob haben und
die fit sind die wollen auch länger
arbeiten also wir haben ja eine so fitte
generation der 70-jährigen wie noch nie
zuvor in der geschichte und deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir langfristig die
durchschnittliche lebenserwartung an die
durchschnittliche lebensarbeitszeit
koppeln zu einem generationen
übergreifenden
mechanismus kommen denn viele andere
europäische länder längst eingeführt
haben erschlossen da würde ich mir
wünschen dass wir vielleicht sogar einen
parteiübergreifenden konsens hinbekommen
ich bin leider das muss ich auch noch
einmal sagen etwas enttäuscht von der
fdp weil ich in der letzten
legislaturperiode auch selber in als cdu
nah gesagt habe da die fdp viele
richtige ansätze die hat den mut gehabt
debatten anzustoßen und jetzt in der
koalition wird nichts umgesetzt der
einzig sinnvolle vorschlag nämlich eine
aktien rente einzuführen ist jetzt auch
noch kassiert worden sie kommen ja kann
man bisher leider noch nichts davon ist
also mein fachwissen müssen wir an alle
sagen wann kommt eigentlich
aktien renten und deswegen muss ich
sagen da hat die ampel koalition bisher
versagt ich kann sagen wir wenn ein cdu
da druck machen dass diese reform auch
durchgeführt werden in dieser
legislaturperiode also was aber alle
sagen die rente ist ein schneeballsystem
geworden im grunde nach dem motto wer
zuletzt im kontext der gelackmeierte
also wenn ich meinen rentenbescheid
öffnet er kommt ja alle paar monate mal
dann denke ich mir naja ist wenn er alle
paar monate kommen die angereisten
möglicherweise auch deshalb vor anderen
leuten also einig kommt da einmal ja
aber wer sagt dass irgendwann der
sebastian geisler ist dann denke ich
irgendwie mensch na ja da muss ich also
von meinem jetzigen lebensstandard der
so rasend rufen eigentlich ist ich lebe
nicht verschwenderisch müsste ich schon
spürbar unter und dann ist muss ist das
ja aber ein betrag der wirksam wird im
jahr in meinem fall 2004 50 oder so wo
ich mich frage was ist denn das dann
eigentlich noch wert dieser betrag stieg
von inflation und steuern und steuern
ging ja auch noch ein jahr das problem
bei solchen reformen ist ja immer dass
die leute wieder gewählt werden rechten
und das reform die schmerzhaft sind in
der regel nicht zu prozentualen
zuwächsen bei den nächsten wahlen führen
das ist deswegen ist die sache so schwer
zu machen die analyse dateien ja glaube
ich alle ich glaube das würde andere
parteien einen tisch setzen würden die
auch das gleich gesagt nur wie macht man
es also was sicher eine einen beitrag
dazu wäre wäre ist die beschäftigung von
älteren arbeitnehmern die arbeiten
möchten zu erleichtern und arbeitgeber
zu motivieren die leute weiter arbeiten
zu lassen das ist glaube ich etwas was
relativ leicht umzusetzen muss man da
gesellschaftlich auch um dinge sollte ja
dann wenn die leute schon ist man mit 50
schon zu alt und wird irgendwie aufs
altenteil rausgedrängt abfindung
unterstützt da muss man schon jetzt als
gesellschafter auch das findet aber
schon automatisch statt weil einfach ist
ein enorm fachkräftemangel gibt das
heißt da sind die unternehmen gezwungen
ich will aber allen auch vielleicht mal
auch in der politik mut machen doch auch
diese debatten zu führen weil ich glaube
das ist ein irrglaube zu sagen na ja die
älteren die denken nur an sich und sagen
nach mir die sintflut ganz viele die
haben ja selber kinder oder enkelkinder
und den ist auch wichtig dass es den
kindern und enkelkindern gut geht und
wenn wir sagen wir wollen das
generationenübergreifend gerecht und
fair aufziehen und auch die lasten
zwischen den generationen gerecht
verteilen da gibt es glaube ich dafür
auch deutlich mehr zustimmung und dann
wird man daraus auch nicht ein kampf
zwischen den generationen machen den ja
eigentlich niemand will ich glaube sie
wissen als junger cdu abgeordneter genau
wie schwer es ist auch in ihrer eigenen
partei mit dem was sie sagen richtig
durchzudringen wenn ich mich an die
letzten wettkämpfe auch der union
erinnere dann war das dürfte das nie ein
renten wahlkampf sein weil man genau vor
dem angst hatte dass es heißt ja dass
weder das renteneintrittsalter es gab
den wissenschaftlichen dienst des
bundeswirtschaftsministers damals peter
altmaier der vier oder fünf monate vor
der bundestagswahl im letzten jahr
gesagt ja wir müssen das retten das
renteneintrittsalter deutlich noch mal
wieder erhöhen und das wurde direkt von
peter altmaier zurückgewiesen nein da
sind unabhängige wissenschaftliche ein
nichts damit zu tun und damit war das
thema aus seiner sicht wieder ad acta
gelegt aber ich glaube es geht ihnen ja
frischen gar nicht um das thema rente
und mich wird dann schon interessiert
hat unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
auch was meinen sie eigentlich mit
sozialreformen das was passieren muss
dass wir immer wieder aber was kommt ich
muss eigentlich passieren es wären ja
auch diesen glücklichen zustand dass wir
immer älter werden also wir haben in der
lebenserwartung also ich sowieso schon
bin glaube ich bei 89 und meine kinder
sind schon über 90 besonders die tochter
und noch vor kurzem noch nicht vor so
langer zeit da ist man halt nicht so alt
geworden und wenn man mit 60 stirbt dann
kann man halt mit 70 nicht ein
schlaganfallpatient
werden und mit 90 kein demenz fall und
diese zahlen der also die prognosen über
die anzahl der dementen die wir in
zukunft haben werden ist
unfassbar also das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen was da auf uns zukommt weil
sie können ja dementen nicht
brauchen eine eins-zu-eins-betreuung wir
stehen doch jetzt schon über mangelnde
pflegekräfte wie soll das gehen ja wie
soll die reform aussehen da haben wir
also ich hab natürlich vorschläge dazu
dass man sie die mal raus ja ich bin ja
ich lebe ja die eigenverantwortung sei
es bei corona bei der
gesundheitsvorsorge da bin ich auch
dafür dass man sich also dass man
eigenen anteil zahlt und bei der
pflegeversicherung könnte ich mir
durchaus eine karenzzeit vorstellen kann
die spd mit macht carlsson hat was lange
sie einmal ganz zu ende die karenzzeit
hat meinen sie was genau ist man
vielleicht so wie es früher war dass die
familie für den zu pflegenden aufkommt
so lange sie sich das leisten können
also nicht das erbschafts
bewegungsprogramm was wir dank der cdu
bekommen haben sondern dass man sagt das
erste jahr dass ein mensch in pflege
kommt das bezahlt man sein also die
kinder quasi
genau wie
haben sie diesen fonds zurück er wird ja
die pflege endet ja mit dem wenn sie
dann den koalitionsvertrag an schon das
ganze kapitel wo es um das thema rente
geht gesetzliche krankenversicherungen
wo es um das thema pflege geht da muss
ihn ja eigentlich dann gerade auch mit
dem vorschuss sehen sie gerade gemacht
haben es kalt über den rücken laufen das
ist ja ein programm er für deutlich mehr
ausgaben und damit auch deutlich höhere
beiträge also von dem was sie fordern
ist ja die koalition in der sie ja auch
mit dabei sind
auf komplett anderen wege quasi sie sind
die geisterfahrerin oder
geisterfahrerin will ich nicht sagen
aber ich bin über die anderen kindern ja
ja und deren ziel ist auch ist später
kinder zu haben und es einfach eine
klare rechnung ich finde es einfach
ich finde es einfach ungerecht in
zukünftigen generationen das zu
überlassen und nicht die in die pflicht
zu nehmen die uns das problem beschert
haben nämlich die die keine kinder
gezeugt haben also so das hört sich
jetzt krass an aber es ist ja nun mal so
die kinder sind nicht die verursacher
des problems in anderen dass man ein
bisschen ausgleich schafft und dass die
mit in die verantwortung gezogen werden
das ist bei der rente vielleicht dass
man man ja länger arbeitet wo man ja
fast 30 jahre also der
durchschnittsrente rentner geht mit 61
in die rente und wird 90 jahre alt also
bezieht ja auch 30 jahre rente es ist
ein ganz der durchschnittsrentner nicht
aber man wird bezieht die frauen
beziehen bestimmt 20 jahre rente und die
männer beziehen glaube ich im schnitt 15
jahre rente also mit ist ja die marine
schon beiden zwei jahre die frauen wenn
auch als 20 da habe ich gerade
nicht schön aber ich will noch mal ein
punkt zahlen also was sie eben
formuliert haben hat ja viele
vernünftige aspekte aber
leider das aber wenn wir jetzt hier ein
sozialdemokraten sitzen hätten dann
würde ja genau das gegenteil sie haben
sie in ihrer partner ja auch das heißt
dass die am becken würden dann merkt man
wer die ampelkoalition die weiß nicht
wohin steuert so und was ich erwartet
ist das natürlich bei allen
unterschieden die eine koalition immer
hat man sich jetzt wirklich auf einen
vernünftigen kompromiss verständigt und
da wirklich auch reformen durchgeführt
werden weil ansonsten passiert nichts
und wir können uns das nicht länger
erlauben ich habe selber auch in der
letzten legislaturperiode da druck
gemacht war auch mit meiner eigenen
partei nicht immer zufrieden sage ich
auch ganz klar und deswegen würde ich
mir wünschen dass wir da vielleicht
sogar parteiübergreifenden konsens
hinbekommen nur die ampel ist der
wirkliche enttäuschung da steht oben
fortschritts koalition drauf aber es ist
eher ein rückschritt koalition sie haben
dass dort herr drost p dabei ist ja und
das wir diskutieren und reformieren also
weil man ja nix immer mehr schuld sein
wenn wir das
beschließen und zu ende denken und da
will ich gleich zu nahe treten aber die
letzten 16 jahre gab es eine
bundeskanzlerin die ära partei angehört
und wir reden über einen ausufernden
sozialstaat deswegen glaube ich weiß
nicht ob die cdu gerade der beste
kronzeuge ist um anzuprangern dass die
ampel jetzt seit 15 monaten
dabei ist gewisse dinge vielleicht
falsch zu machen erste große koalition
hat wichtige rentenreform durchgeführt
wir haben über das thema rente
gesprochen sozialstaat wir müssten
länger darüber reden aber herr plus sie
haben auch noch ein thema dabei das
ebenfalls extrem wichtig ist und
deswegen blenden wir jetzt dahin leider
müssen wir in den letzten jahren immer
mehr antijüdische demonstrationen in
deutschlands großstädten sehen wir haben
in deutschland zu recht sehr stark den
fokus darauf dass der rechtsextremismus
eine große gefahr darstellt und dass es
leider sehr starken rechtsextrem
hass auf juden gibt aber was häufig
vergessen wird bei der ganzen debatte
ist dass mancher islamismus leider nach
deutschland importiert wird der
judenhass der immer mehr um sich greift
gerade in deutschlands großstädten der
kommt teilweise aus arabischen staaten
nach deutschland wir haben gesehen in
den vergangenen jahren kommen menschen
nach deutschland die das judentum an
sich ablehnen und das können wir als
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht
akzeptieren wir brauchen eine ehrliche
debatte die in alle richtungen schaut
die sich den die den rechtsextremismus
beleuchtet die den linksextremismus
beleuchtet die sich aber auch mit
islamismus auseinandersetzt und den
fokus darauf legt dass aus all diesen
extremistischen er wurzeln judenhass
resultiert und deswegen mein plädoyer
wir brauchen in deutschland eine
ehrliche debatte darüber und wir
brauchen harte konsequenzen damit der
hass auf unsere jüdischen mitbürger ein
ende hat und damit wir die bilder die
wir gerade auch in den vergangenen tagen
in deutschlands großstädten sehen
mussten endlich ein ende haben
ich finde es toll dass sie das so
aussprechen denn es ist ja so dass wir
in deutschland eigentlich eine
meinungsklima ist wo man nach wie vor
den eindruck hat es kostet ein
eigentlich überwindung und es braucht
mut diese dinge so mann zu sprechen
obwohl das ja phänomene sind die ja
jedes kind eigentlich sehen kann man
sich ja diese aggressiven männer man
hört was die rufen man weiß woher sie
kommen man weiß warum sie bei uns im
land sind man weiß was wir probleme wir
haben mit einer ungeregelten zuwanderung
das sind alles themen die man dringend
in angriff nehmen musste und dennoch
sind wir nach wie vor eine situation die
flüchtlingskrise begann jahr 2015 das
ist jetzt schon sieben jahre her
ungefähr dass wir eigentlich nicht die
richtigen konsequenzen gezogen hat also
wenn frau teresa unsere innenministerin
immer noch sagt es gibt rechten
antisemitismus und antisemitismus egal
von wem so in dem sinne äußert sie sich
ja oft und nicht klar benennt als
innenministerin es gibt linksextremismus
es gibt diesen islamismus es gibt
islamistischen antisemitismus einfach
das problem benennen da sind wir noch
nicht auf der ebene der lösung der sind
wir auf der ebene des benennen wenn sie
das nicht tut dann zeigt das dass wir
ein ganz großes problem haben und auch
einer lösung nicht näher kommen k+s ist
uns doch allen klar was passieren würde
wenn sie das was sie da gerade eben
erzählt haben in einem anderen forum
erzählen
vielleicht in mancher
redaktionskonferenz manches mediums sie
hören den rassismus-vorwurf das ist das
was passiert natürlich ist dieser
vorwurf unsinnig aber warum wird er
erhoben er wird erhoben weil es eine
immer mächtiger werdende
ideologie gibt in deutschland an den
universitäten in der gesellschaft auch
in manchen parteien die besagt alle
weißen sind rassisten und alle menschen
die eine andere hautfarbe haben sind
rassismus opfer zu den rassismus opfer
die das qua geburt sind ja nicht
durcheinander qua geburt gehören auch
leute aus arabischen ländern zu den
weißen werden oft die juden gerechnet es
gibt da unterschiedliche schattierungen
das heißt wir haben es ich will so hart
sagen wir haben es mit der art neuem
rassismus zu tun der menschen nach
hautfarben sortiert und der
instrumentalen instrumentalisiert wird
um den rassismus über den sie zu recht
gesprochen haben nämlich dem gegen
jüdische menschen in diesem land zu
verschleiern das ist ein großes problem
und gegen diese ideologie muss man
aufstehen finde ich wenn man in der lage
sein möchte auch noch in zukunft zu
sagen was ist hermetisch das was sie da
gerade ansprechend ist ja diese
sogenannte kritiker race theorie die
kompost ist ich halte das wie gesagt ich
wollte es nicht zu kompliziert für eine
so er so für eine eigentlich progressiv
gewandete apartheids lehre das ist
entsetzlich dass so etwas sich in
unserer gesellschaft wieder verbreitet
das ist tatsächlich eine gefährliche
ideologie was mich entsetzt hat ist ich
habe diese ideologie kürzlich postuliert
verbreitet gesehen auf einer seite des
bundesfamilienministeriums so weit ist
es gekommen das ist schlimm aber es
stellt sich dem ja offensichtlich auch
kaum jemand entgegen weil die menschen
angst haben sie werden dann als
rassisten irgendwie beschimpft oder so
es müssen weil er ja noch mal sozusagen
eine andere debatte ist also ich habe
endlich fliegen aber wenn wir genau also
ich hab das auch in den vergangenen
jahren immer wieder gemacht aber was ich
auch gemerkt habe ist bei den debatten
wenn man diese bilder sieht davon
großdemonstration gegen das judentum wir
haben einmal kurz tag
demonstration in anführungszeichen
kurstag
gegen jüdische mitbürger das ist
teilweise bilder die furchtbar sind
gerade auch mit blick auf die geschichte
unseres landes und wir haben ein
erkenntnisproblem in teilen der politik
gerade bei spd und grünen weil spd und
grüne häufig sagen na ja das kommt nur
von rechts oder rechtsaußen da gibt es
in der tat auch schlimmen antisemitismus
aber es gibt eben auch importierten
antisemitismus und darüber müssen wir
auch eine ehrliche debatte führen denn
migrationspolitik wird in deutschland
auf dauer nur erfolgreich sein wenn sie
klar nach regeln verläuft und wenn wir
nicht nur sagen ihr habt auch gewisse
rechte wenn ihr nach deutschland kommt
sondern ihr habt auch pflichten und wir
haben als gesellschaft eine erwartung an
all diejenigen die hier zu uns ziehen
und wer das judentum ablehnt und das
judentum zerstören will der hat in
deutschland nichts zu suchen schade dass
frau merkel das nicht dort hat im jahr
2015 was sie gerade gesagt haben
ja das ist und möglicherweise haben sie
ist 2015 sogar gesagt was wurde trotzdem
nicht gehört frau raffelhüschen wie
offen wird in der ampel auch genau über
dieses thema gesprochen
haben sie den eindruck dass sie so ein
thema auch wie wir es jetzt hier
diskutieren ebenfalls mit kollegen und
kollegen der grünen und der spd genauso
diskutieren könnten ohne dass man ihnen
gleich das was harald martenstein auch
sagte vorwirft sie sind aber doch
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen sehr
rassistisch unterwegs
das thema ist so noch nicht gefallen wir
haben jetzt haushaltsverhandlungen und
ich habe jetzt gerade ein
berichterstatter gespräch mit dem
familienministerium und das sind auch
posten für also gelder für anti
antisemitismus programme und wenn man
dann fragt ja was sind das für projekte
wie teilt sich das auf also
linksextremismus rechtsextremismus und
und dann es ist so nicht aufgelistet man
muss das dann einfordern und wir gucken
uns das ganz genau an wie das verhältnis
ist weil wie sie schon sagen also da
muss auch was getan muss die ampel
aufstocken brauchen braucht deutschland
muss deutschland muss die
bundesregierung mehr in projekte stecken
mehr geld in projekte stecken die sich
speziell um das thema
islamistische antisemit ist wenn es nach
mir ginge ich wäre dafür dass wir setzen
sich in haushaltsverhandlungen wir
gucken uns jetzt erst mal an wie sind
die verhältnisse wie viel geld fließt wo
hin und dann werden wir also ich werde
mich darum herum das ist ein ausgleich
klar das hat das die große koalition
bisher nicht gemacht dann in der großen
koalition das muss man wirklich sagen
ist auf initiative der cdu sehr vielen
die sicherheitsorgane investiert worden
also die mittel sind deutlich erhöht
worden kann man sich klar anschauen das
ist aus meiner sicht auch gar nicht das
hauptproblem sondern das hauptproblem
ist ein erkenntnisproblem das nehme ich
immer nur gesagt wird na ja das kommt
vor allem von rechtsaußen der
antisemitismus das ist richtig und daher
wir müssen gegen jeglichen
antisemitismus von rechtsaußen als
gesellschaft alles tun aber der
importierte
islamismus der importierte
antisemitismus der spielt häufig nicht
die rolle und deswegen muss erstmal
diese erkenntnis da sein und dann kann
man auch relativ einfach politische
maßnahmen ableiten deswegen ja auch
dieses motto je dass das endlich mit auf
die agenda in deutschland kommt aber
einfluss politischer maßnahmen also ein
aggressiver junger mann nicht deutscher
staatsbürger mit im zuge der migrations
krise gekommen der juden auf der straße
an greift solche sehen gab es ja schon
in berlin in vergangenen jahren was muss
passieren muss der außer landes gebracht
also ich bin ich bin dafür dass also
jeder der solche taten verübte er muss
nach möglichkeit sofort abgeschoben
werden oder er muss die konsequenzen des
rechtsstaates mit aller herrlich würden
mit aller härte spüren meine damen und
herren das war ein gutes schlusswort von
christoph ploß wir hatten heute der
sendung claudia raffelhüschen harald
martenstein christoph ploß und sebastian
geisler mein name ist ein schäfer
bedanke mich ganz herzlich für ihr
interesse hoffe dass sie eine spannende
sendung genossen haben und ich freue
mich wenn wir uns dann demnächst um 48
wiedersehen machen sie es gut einen
schönen abend seine gute nacht auch
wieder schauen
[Musik]